you you go to the side and you you shape
your hands like this
right
shape your hands like this
notice the back foot
it sort of lands
softly
if you can get that
then you can get that
if you put the hat foot down firmly
it becomes like a pull and a push
and and you'll never throw them but if
you
all right so the
all right so so this is what we're
looking for
okay if you want to do that on your
as long as you make sure you throw off
the mat
it smells bad enough as it is all right
i think we've got it don't worry at all
okay
uh what what most of you doing what
watch his back hand
where's the joe nowhere near my hand
so now i'm
i'm wasting time
in in my uh
the green book those have got my green
book will say don't go backwards to go
forwards and it's something that i'm
always repeating
and what it really means is if you've
got to go
up there it was down here wasn't it my
hand
if it's got to go up here now just go
back down there
i've actually wasted
a movement so i'm going
backwards to now go forwards again
so
you don't know you're doing it's almost
like oh i didn't know i was doing that
but
he sadly ended up not a very good chat
but bruce clicksteen
from america he was the best i've ever
seen apart from saito scentsy and he
would go
[Applause]
you know and you could see this
he'd be sucking you in and all of a
sudden pump this power would come out
but i learned this off him
this this
all right so so just check where your
hand is because without you knowing
you're actually putting yourself to a
disadvantage by going and then by the
time you go there you've now got to pull
it and push it
all right okay
it's a good uk